IAN NI-LEWIS: Hello and welcome
back to the Friday
Games Review.
I am Ian Ni-Lewis.
DAN GALPIN: And I'm
Dan Galpin.
And we're going to be looking at
a bunch of Halloween games
as well as chatting, as we
always do, talking about the
technology behind games and how
we can make more awesome
games on Android.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And, sad to say,
this is the final episode of
the Friday Games Review.
We've both moved on.
[LAUGHING]
DAN GALPIN: We've
both moved on.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
You know, at some point, you
gotta ask yourself, how much
beer am I going to
drink for my job?
And the answer is, a lot.
And now--
DAN GALPIN: I think that part
will continue, though.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh,
you never know.
Anyway, so today we're
drinking, again,
Rogue Dead Guy Ale.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Because it's
Halloweeny, and because this
show is dead.
Now we're not going off
the air permanently.
We're going to be back
at some point.
I think Dan's going to be
headlining a new act, trying
to get something together
with maybe Colt
McAnlis or those guys.
Basically, what's happened is
it used to be all about
Android with us.
And now, Dan's sort of taken on
a role that is more global,
a little bit more
cross-Google.
And I think that as soon as he's
ready to talk about that,
I think he's going to come back
with some cool stuff.
DAN GALPIN: Basically, it means
that I could spend a lot
of time with Colt and with Todd
Kerpelman and a bunch of
other people here, and that's
going to be great.
And I'm trying to encourage
them to wear
crazy hats as well.
So we'll see.
Hopefully we'll see more crazy
hats in the future.
By the way, this hat is not just
a crazy hat with hair,
which is partially in honor of
the amazing picture that was
put together by Daniel
Pham in response to
our fauxhawk comments--
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Last week, we--
DAN GALPIN: Comments
from last week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We intimated that
perhaps Daniel Pham was
in New York and London
for the semiannual
fauxhawk fashion week.
And apparently, Dan took
that the wrong way.
DAN GALPIN: I think he took
it the right way.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Not prepared
to come out as a
fauxhawk guy, I guess.
anyway, he was kind enough
to put together this.
Dan went--
DAN GALPIN: And it's something
like that.
So speaking of stronger, so the
hat that I'm wearing, if
you can't tell, is actually a
San Francisco Giants hat.
And no, I did not get to go and
attend the World Series.
But I did stand outside of the
ballpark yesterday and watch
the end of the game.
And it was kind of epic
just being there with
the cheering fans.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You watched
the end of the
game outside the ballpark?
DAN GALPIN: On televisions
literally in the plaza in
front of the ballpark.
And it was great because we had
about a 10-second delay.
So when anything would happen in
the game that was awesome,
we'd hear the cheers
from them.
And then 10 seconds later, you'd
hear the cheers from us
all waiting outside in the less
than cheap standing area.
But it was awesome and epic, and
it was exciting to see the
Giants go up 2-0, for
all those who are
Giants fans out there.
And yeah, so this hat is
actually a SF Giants hat.
But it also just kind of fits
with the fauxhawk theme we had
from last week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, the
thing about your fauxhawk is,
it really didn't turn
into a fauxhawk.
I mean, mine was--
I don't even know
what mine was.
I think it was a--
so epic, it makes me want to put
you on the cover of a '70s
funk album.
It's Doug Henning.
It's like, you are the '70s
magician, the groovy magician
of Android.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, something
like that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Bringing
mullets back.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Can we see that
with the motion, Dan?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, let's--
you mean this with the motion?
DANIEL PHAM: Yeah, do
you want to see--
DAN GALPIN: Or do you want
me to do the motion?
Oh, I see.
Yeah, absolutely, with
the work that Ian has
put together to make--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
DAN GALPIN: --to make
me more epic.
I don't think I could look
at myself that often.
But I'll mention it
to my girlfriend.
She might like it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I wasn't
talking to you.
DAN GALPIN: Oh.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I was talking
to everyone out there in
Internet-land.
DAN GALPIN: So, we do--
now last week, I challenged
you all to
nominate Halloweeny games.
And of course, that
didn't happen.
So instead, I'm going to
talk about a bunch
of Halloween games.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think it's
because there were like two
people watching, and one
of them was my wife.
DAN GALPIN: Probably,
probably.
Yeah.
Yeah, you should have
nominated some
games, Ian's wife.
But in all fairness, so
we are going to cover
some Halloween games.
There was one game that's
sort of borderline.
I also wanted to mention that
"Greedy Spiders" actually went
and got updated based
upon the comments we
made from last week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Rock on.
DAN GALPIN: So thanks,
guys, for doing that.
I've definitely let the
Google Play team know.
And as soon as they're out from
under the epic burden
they've been under in the last
week or so, hopefully we'll
see something happen with that
because it's a great game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it's worth
mentioning, too, the amazing
burden that these people
put themselves under
every holiday season.
It's really, really difficult
to be a Google Play
merchandising guy in
any holiday season.
So remember to get those updates
up two, three weeks
beforehand if you want
to be considered for
featuring at a holiday.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it's
totally brutal.
It kind of works, though.
Because as far as I can tell in
this country, Christmas is
now beginning in August.
That was when I first saw the
Christmas merchandise showing
up in stores, was in August
of this year.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What?
DAN GALPIN: I know
IAN NI-LEWIS: What store
had Christmas
merchandise in August?
DAN GALPIN: Costco, actually,
was like--
I was totally amazed.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I guess they
have to truck it in.
DAN GALPIN: So in any case,
given that, having something
up two or three weeks before
the holiday actually is a
really good idea.
If you are a game team, and you
are just trucking to get
something done the day before
the holiday, and then you want
the team to have time to look
at it, that's probably not
going to happen, especially when
the team is also trying
to prepare for an event that's
going to happen on Monday.
So--
and not that we can talk about
what that event will be, other
than the playground is open.
Isn't that what they
said about it?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Is that really
what we said? "The
playground is open"?
DAN GALPIN: I think that's
what we said,
something like that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Wow,
how exciting.
DAN GALPIN: I know, I know.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to
that event actually happening
so that life can go back
to normal, right?
Yeah?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I hope so.
DAN GALPIN: I hope so.
Of course, then, with this
hair, who knows?
So I did look at a bunch
of games this week.
The first one is "Gun Zombie
Halloween." Now, honestly, if
"Gun Zombie" by itself was not
Halloweeny enough, we have the
Gun Zombie Halloween edition.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Whoa.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
So just to show you--
IAN NI-LEWIS: So I think what
we want to do today is rate
games on A, how good they are
and B, how shamelessly they
chiseled in some sort
of Halloween theme--
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Whether or
not it fit, right?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And actually, most of the ones
I picked today really were
games that should have had
a Halloween theme.
So I didn't look out
for the ones that
were shameless, like--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Did you get
"Clouds and Sheep"?
DAN GALPIN: I did not put
"Clouds and Sheep" Halloween
edition up there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But shoutout to
our buddies at HandyGames.
DAN GALPIN: Dudes, awesome
job with that one.
So this one here, your job is
to shoot things as they walk
towards you, thus eliminating
them from having to actually
have a view of anything
from the side,
which is kind of epic.
And basically, you shoot, you
reload, and then you have
these nice splash effects that
happen on the screen.
It sort of makes me feel like
they used the engine from the
original "Wolfenstein 3D" here
in terms of complexity.
But hey, it works.
It's sort of 3D-ish.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What's
your beef there?
DAN GALPIN: There's
no beef, no.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It looks good.
DAN GALPIN: The game
is minimal beef.
But that's kind of the problem,
also, is it's kind of
a lot of the same gameplay.
My biggest complaint with this
is that if you're going to do
a game in which you're
interacting with a
touchscreen, and you have a
whole bunch of things that are
running towards you, I hate
actually having to move my gun
with a virtual joystick.
At this point, I just want to
go tap, tap, tap, tap, tap.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, what's
up with that?
What is up with that,
seriously?
DAN GALPIN: I know, I now.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right?
DAN GALPIN: But I wanted to
mention it because it was
actually a nicely themed
Halloween game.
Let's go on to some
other stuff.
Now this is "Zombiewood,"
which is the big--
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know,
let's take a break
and talk about Monday.
Because that was epic.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, this Monday?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So last Monday, we went down
to San Jose with the
HandyGames guys, who were
in from Germany, right?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And they had never really
watched much baseball.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, it turns
out that Viking dude had.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, Viking
dude had.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We don't actually
know their names.
We just know--
DAN GALPIN: That's Chris.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There's Viking
dude, Viking dude's brother--
DAN GALPIN: Marcus.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And
the accountant.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, yeah,
I don't know him.
He's the accountant.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's not
actually a description.
That's a superpower, actually.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
it is, it is.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So Viking
dude is telling me--
I sit down, and I'm like, well,
he probably doesn't
really like baseball.
So I'm like, hey, show
me your game.
And he's like, shut up, dude.
And I'm like--
DAN GALPIN: I'm watching
the game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you're
really into this.
And he's like, yeah.
Because apparently, the bar
he likes to drink at is a
baseball bar.
DAN GALPIN: Well, of course.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And so you can't,
like, drink with those
people unless you
know baseball.
DAN GALPIN: Well, I will say
this bar, by the way--
IAN NI-LEWIS: The bar we were
in-- this is why I wanted to
bring it up--
DAN GALPIN: Firehouse 1 down in
San Pedro Square, you have
the rocking beer collection.
I mean, honestly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So they were
like, oh, we've got this
Belgian that's on special.
I'm like, oh, I'll
try that, fully
expecting it to be terrible.
A, it was a really good beer.
Think Hoegaarden, but--
DAN GALPIN: Better.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Less commercial.
Just awesome.
Second, they brought it to me
in a glass that, I kid you
not, was shaped like one of
those old-timey bicycle horns,
you know, with the
bulb and the--
DAN GALPIN: Hand-shaped
glass, clearly.
You like that?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right?
DAN GALPIN: And a stand.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
a wooden stand.
DAN GALPIN: Because otherwise
the glass would fall over,
that clearly came from the
origin of the beer.
So this was beer that was on
tap that was served in a
specialized mug the way they
would have in Belgium.
And I have to say, big
thumbs up there.
Not to mention all of the other
beer selections were
epic, including the Duchesse,
which is one of my--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Duchesse De
Bourgogne, yeah, one of our
favorite beers, absolutely.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
so it was epic.
Not only that, it was an epic
game because the Giants kicked
some serious booty.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, they did.
I don't know.
Epic--
I mean, it was kind
of lopsided.
DAN GALPIN: It was.
But the end of the game, the
rain pouring down, and they
had people on--
oh wait.
That was the other
game, wasn't it?
Never mind.
There was a lot of epicness
this week.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, you
remember, it was like the
rain, and then there was that
one dude, and then I think
Robert Redford hit a homer and
all the lights went out--
DAN GALPIN: No, actually, in all
seriousness, it was Monday
night, the rain was coming
down, it was
the end of the game.
And yeah, it was truly, truly
epic to end that series.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway, thanks for
HandyGames for suggesting
that place.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Because it turned
out to be awesome.
And it's like within walking
distance from my house.
DAN GALPIN: Which
is a good thing.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Which you can't
say about very many places,
both awesome and within
walking distance.
DAN GALPIN: The Pink Poodle's
was walking
distance of your house.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I have no opinion
about the Pink Poodle.
DAN GALPIN: Anyways,
all right.
So this is "Zombiewood,"
by the way.
And it's a two-stick shooter.
And as far as I can tell,
Gameloft made very, very
little effort to actually make
it run well on a Tegra 3,
which is kind of sad
because this is--
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's tough.
I mean, like we've talked about
before, Tegra 3's kind
of the odd man out on some
of these things.
It's a fully forward renderer,
which means that you've got to
sort your geometry.
You've got to do all
the sort of PC
things, in terms of like--
DAN GALPIN: So in all fairness,
so before coming in
here, I actually put this
through PerfHUD.
And PerfHUD, for those
who don't know, is
NVIDIA's truly epic--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, you put it
through PerfHUD, but you
didn't bring it in here
to show everyone?
Did you bring enough for
the whole class?
DAN GALPIN: I-- definitely.
So just to mention, PerfHUD
is NVIDIA's
awesome performance tool.
It runs only on NVIDIA chips,
but you can actually go
through and honestly get an
amazing amount of information
about how your GL screens
are rendering.
It really is an amazing,
amazing tool.
And I was able to discern
immediately that this app was
[? ridge ?] rendering.
The first thing it puts up on
the screen is the background,
which you know is a bad sign.
And it does--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
A lot of people don't
realize this.
I am shocked at how many people
don't realize this.
There is one basic, basic lesson
that you all must learn
if you want your graphics
to be fast.
And that is, you have a
background and/or skybox, they
get drawn last.
Every single GPU ever will do
better if you draw your skybox
and background last.
DAN GALPIN: Except for one.
Except for one.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dude, what?
Which one?
DAN GALPIN: The Imagination
Technologies GPUs don't
fricking care.
They actually draw just
as well either way.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK, I'm sorry.
Everything will do at least
as well or better.
DAN GALPIN: Ah, there we are.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I can't
believe you, man.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, yeah.
So basically--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually, no.
They sort, but they
also Z reject.
DAN GALPIN: They sort, but
the problem is they sort
everything.
And so since it re-sorts it
after you send it to it, it
actually wastes just
as much time.
So you waste more CPU sorting
your geography.
The thing about this game,
though, is it's isometric
projection, dudes.
So there's very little sorting
that has to go on here.
Objects are barely ever on
top of each other in
a meaningful way.
The objects are always
on the background.
And none of these objects
have transparency--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Hey,
you know what?
DAN GALPIN: Translucency.
You know why?
IAN NI-LEWIS: It doesn't
cost any CPU to
draw your skybox last.
That's not a sorting
operation.
DAN GALPIN: No, that's
what I mean.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's just
drawing your skybox and/or
background last.
DAN GALPIN: This isn't
even a skybox.
This is the floor.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So there
is no cost to this.
You would have to be stupid
to not do this.
DAN GALPIN: Are you calling
Gameloft stupid?
Are you calling Gameloft
stupid?
Because you know, we don't do
that here on this show.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I meant
everybody-- wait.
DAN GALPIN: OK, we do.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Are you saying
like a carve-out or something?
We call everybody stupid
on this show.
DAN GALPIN: That's true,
especially us.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Especially
ourselves.
DAN GALPIN: Well said.
So anyways, yeah, if you don't
mind the game running at about
10 frames a second, it's
actually pretty
fun on Nexus 7.
I'm hoping that we can convince
Gameloft to actually
do a little bit of geometry
sorting at some point.
Obviously, this game came out
just before Halloween.
They were probably just
rushing to try to
get it out the door.
Congratulations for
simulshipping
it on multiple platforms.
But now it's time to
actually make the
Android version run better.
It's just too slow.
And honestly, I love these
kind of games.
I love dual-stick
shooters, man.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And it's tough
because right now, Tegra has a
really large market
share for--
DAN GALPIN: People who
care about games.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Large devices,
yeah, tablet devices.
All right, so we made a joke
earlier about year of the
Android tablet, year of the
Linux desktop, whatever.
But the truth is that Android
tablets have been gaining more
and more market share.
Now it's true that
there's some--
the Galaxy Note, you could
probably call a tablet.
DAN GALPIN: It's a fablet.
It's kind of like the
fauxhawk, OK?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
So, but--
DAN GALPIN: Well done.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
you took the words
right out of my mouth.
DAN GALPIN: Well done, Daniel.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The point is a lot
of large devices use the
Tegra 3 for whatever reason.
And at this point, it's unwise
to ignore this chip.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
And honestly, the tools
are so good.
The thing is, no matter what
you think of the chip,
NVIDIA's tools are so, so
awesome at being able to spot
these things.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yep.
Also, if you're a
game developer
with any kind of pedigree--
yes.
DAN GALPIN: Awesome.
There we are.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
DAN GALPIN: Speaking
of awesome--
IAN NI-LEWIS: If you've got
any kind of chops, you've
released some cool stuff on
any platform, NVIDIA will
often talk to you and give
you lots of help.
They're really good at that.
They have basically an army of
people like me and Dan, except
they know a lot more about
their particular chip.
And they will do amazing
things for you.
DAN GALPIN: You could
just say "know a lot
more." I'm OK with that.
Actually, they don't have
an army of people
that know a lot more.
They've got two or
three guys--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN GALPIN: There's the dude
from North Carolina--
Lars, you're awesome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I think
we're just going to spend the
rest of the show giving
shoutouts to people.
DAN GALPIN: That's right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Especially
our buddy in Austria.
I can't remember your YouTube
channel right now.
And you're probably
not even watching.
But peace, brother.
DANIEL PHAM: I think
his name is Marcus.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You're right,
DAN GALPIN: His name is Marcus,
same as the brother
who is actually the
CTO of HandyGames.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Viking dude?
DAN GALPIN: No, the brother
of Viking dude,
Marcus, is the CTO.
So yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway, let's--
whoa, what happened?
DAN GALPIN: So by the way, this
is to show, like, if you
ever had any question that Tegra
could do some pretty
awesome stuff, this water
is kind of killer.
My congratulations to the team
over at Madfinger for actually
making this water happen.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, there is one
thing that's really nice
about forward rendering.
And that's that you never have
to worry about a resolve.
Everything's always
getting rendered.
And if you need to take whatever
you've rendered and
use it in a different part
of the scene, that's
considerably faster.
DAN GALPIN: My favorite
part is that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So actually, so we
were talking about the Mali
600 series last week.
And I seem to remember that they
are a deferred renderer,
but they do not sort geometry
before rendering.
DAN GALPIN: That's correct.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So will they also
benefit from CPU sorting,
do you think?
DAN GALPIN: They absolutely
benefit from-- they actually--
IAN NI-LEWIS: They certainly
will benefit from drawing the
skybox last.
Hello!
No, seriously, I've been dealing
with this ever since I
was on the Xbox and Xbox 360.
We'd do performance
reviews of people.
And it's like, oh, wow.
And these are like big games.
I won't mention which company I
visited Edinborough to check
this out on.
But for at least a few of
their builds, they were
drawing their nine-pass
skybox first.
And the thing is, GPUs are
really, really good at
figuring out which pixels
are occluded, most GPUs.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And that's
something that they can
completely optimize away.
So if you've got a skybox and/or
background that is
occluded by masses of other
geometry, be it skyscrapers or
HUD or anything else, it would
behoove you to draw that last.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely
it would.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And in addition,
that's another thing.
Like if you draw an opaque HUD,
you should totally draw
that first.
And you should totally make as
much of it opaque as possible.
Now alpha-blended HUDs
look better.
And I'm not going to tell
you to make your HUD
opaque for no reason.
DAN GALPIN: Well, you
can easily make
part of the HUD opaque.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, yeah.
If you have any part of the HUD
that can be opaque, every
single pixel in there is another
pixel that you don't
have to calculate with
any shaders.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So really, if you're going to
be super, super smart, take
all the opaque areas, make some
geometry for them, draw
those first, and then take all
the non-opaque regions and
draw them last.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Awesome.
I just got a message on
my Amp'd Mobile phone.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN GALPIN: Apparently, someone
has been watching
acceptable.tv.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Get this phone.
It's the only phone that
makes you happy.
It's a Galaxy Nexus world.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I would
say this is not an
Amp'd Mobile phone.
But that's--
good shoutout there, though.
So I showed off "Dead Trigger"
mostly because they added the
cool pumpkin zombies.
And that was their
Halloween add.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's
pretty cool, yeah.
DAN GALPIN: And I like
the pumpkin zombies.
So another game that came
out this week in the--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Hang
on, hang on.
I need a refill.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, another beer.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, OK.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You're
closer, dude.
DAN GALPIN: I am, I am.
All right.
Why aren't you using
the mug, man?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I know, I know.
DAN GALPIN: You brought
the mug all the way--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Here's
the thing.
No, give me the mug.
Give me the mug.
Because you're right.
What an asshole thing to do.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I didn't
say that.
Anyway--
DAN GALPIN: No, you didn't.
But it's--
the show's getting cancelled
already, sir.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's true.
But I still have my
job, I think.
Anyway, so we're out
with HandyGames.
They brought in these awesome
Franconian mugs.
And we didn't drink out of them
because Dan forgot his
because Dan is incredibly
lame.
Notwithstanding the
fact that--
DAN GALPIN: I'm wearing
this hair.
IAN NI-LEWIS: He brought a
massively awesome hat.
That's pretty epic.
Everything Dan does is epic.
We've kind of come
to expect that.
Anyway, so mug advertising game
that you probably can't
read, which is good because--
DAN GALPIN: "Epic
Battle Dude."
IAN NI-LEWIS: Because they told
us to stop advertising
games on our show.
DAN GALPIN: Oh.
Who did?
Wait.
IAN NI-LEWIS: The Man.
And when I say "The Man,"
I mean Billy.
You know, it's funny, because
I asked Billy
to come on the show.
And I'm like, would you at least
do a five-minute spot
disavowing all knowledge
of this show?
And he said no.
DAN GALPIN: Aw.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, anyway--
DAN GALPIN: So this game
actually comes--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Ooh, it's our
favorite company, Yng.
Yng!
DAN GALPIN: So this is "Zombie
Swipeout," which like many--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh man, have
they trademarked that?
Because I could see an entire
Swipeout dynasty.
DAN GALPIN: It's possible.
And this game comes from their
team in Germany, which
actually does not do freemium
social games,
believe it or not.
This is a game that is
actually-- well, like a lot of
other games--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Whoa!
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, so
your goal here--
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's
a lot of fru--
what is that?
DAN GALPIN: I'm trying to
kill zombies that are
jumping up in the air.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, but
what's the fruit?
DAN GALPIN: Oh, those
are coins.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh,
those are coins.
They look like oranges to me.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, no,
those are coins.
They do look a lot
like oranges.
The goal is to avoid killing
your friends--
your friend, in this case, who
looks like he should be killed
because he looks
really unhappy.
But he's being chucked
up in the air among a
whole bunch of zombies.
And to catch the coins.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Where's
your friend?
DAN GALPIN: Hold on.
He'll be there.
I'll swipe him eventually.
There he is.
See the guy?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, dude.
That guy is such a tool.
DAN GALPIN: I know, exactly.
So you gotta--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Look at that
thing he's wearing, too.
That's like a Marty McFly, "Back
to the Future" vest.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
Whoa, and there's multiples of
him because he's got clones.
Anyways, this is a bizarre
game, by the way.
But it's actually really
fun and well done.
And so congratulations
to the team for that.
And it actually, being that it
has actual zombies, and the
zombies are actually part of
the regular game, it's a
pretty good one to release
around Halloween.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
DAN GALPIN: So there we are.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Good stuff.
Wow.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So yeah,
but here's the thing.
What does this add to, let's
say, some sort of Asian
martial arts style game
involving fruit?
DAN GALPIN: Well, it's a
slightly different game
design, but yes.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well,
yeah, and it's OK.
I mean, there's lots of
first-person shooters.
I'm sure there's lots of
ninja swiping games.
But why would I get this?
DAN GALPIN: Well, my feeling was
if you're going to go all
the way and have zombies coming
at you, the whole point
of zombies is that they're
supposed to be coming at you.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, they're
supposed to coming at you at a
slow, terrible pace.
DAN GALPIN: Or even
at a fast pace.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I mean, you
can outrun them, but
they can't be stopped.
They don't sleep.
DAN GALPIN: Brains.
IAN NI-LEWIS: They don't need
to eat except for brains.
Basically, when you're in the
zombie apocalypse, that's the
terrifying thing, right?
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: --funny.
DAN GALPIN: These are
cute zombies.
That's the whole point.
So I don't know why we were
killing them in the air.
Their first game was
"ZombieSmash," which was a
physics game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That was another
flying zombie game.
DAN GALPIN: Flying
zombie game.
So this is the sequel.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Basically, these
guys love zombies in the air.
I want to understand where
that comes from.
Is this some sort of bizarre
German myth that I just am not
familiar with?
Like when you find out that
Hansel and Gretel really died?
DAN GALPIN: Isn't it a German
director who made all those--
yeah, I don't know,
I don't know.
It's a good point.
IAN NI-LEWIS: A German director
made all those what?
DAN GALPIN: Oh, "Resident
Evil" films.
Wasn't--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Was it
a German director?
DAN GALPIN: I don't remember.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It wasn't that
dude that hauled the steamboat
up the mountain, was it?
All right, anyway.
DAN GALPIN: So that's
"Swipeout." We
really liked it.
Or actually, I really
liked it.
But yes, it is a lot like
another game in which one is
battling fruit.
So whether it makes more sense
to battle fruit or battle
zombies that are flying
through the air, you--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Who tossed
them, too?
That's my question.
Who tosses--
DAN GALPIN: Who is tossing
the zombies?
IAN NI-LEWIS: "Fruit Ninja"
I can understand because
obviously, it's your sensei
and/or Asian assistant tossing
stuff in the air so that
you can prove your
ninja skills, right?
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely, right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: This,
I don't know.
DAN GALPIN: I have to admit that
the whole premise behind
this game does completely
escape me.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I don't remember,
it used to be when
you got a game, you
got a box with it,
and there was a manual.
And you would read the manual,
and it would explain this
whole story of why this pixel
hated this other pixel.
DAN GALPIN: You know, I feel
like when one should say that,
I remember when games used to
come with a manual and a box.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, right.
You know what?
Loading screens, uphill
both ways.
DAN GALPIN: So speaking of
loading screens, I wanted to
show off "Nun Attack," which
also has a nice Halloween
theme, believe it or not.
And "Nun Attack"--
IAN NI-LEWIS: This is nothing
compared to "Kung-Fu CB Mamas
on Wheels vs. the Motorcycle
Aztec Wrestling Nuns."
DAN GALPIN: What?
All right, hold on.
I just want to restart this
from the beginning.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what I
don't understand is, "Nun
Attack," is this--
DAN GALPIN: So look.
'Verifying resources." Why is
it verifying resources?
Because I put it into
the code sample.
Gah, you don't have to verify
resources every single time
you run the game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Did you put
it into the code sample?
DAN GALPIN: I did.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Do you know
whose fault this is?
DAN GALPIN: Mine.
Just the fact that
we're waiting all
this time, my fault.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So if you've
ever been in a profession
where you write sample code of
any kind, one thing that you
will note is that sample
code gets cut and
pasted all the time.
It's so funny because
I literally--
DAN GALPIN: I'm glad that they
did change the UI, though.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So at Microsoft,
we were in a position where we
often looked at other
people's code.
I would find samples
that I had written.
And there were comments saying,
"This is sample code.
Do not cut and paste this code,"
cut and pasted into
their code.
I mean, that is how lazy
some developers are.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, so basically,
the answer is--
first of all, are you saying--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, I'm sorry.
Did I say "lazy"?
I meant awesome.
DAN GALPIN: Awesome!
Wait, put up the awesome.
Come on, we need the awesome.
So then it--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh yeah.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
So--
IAN NI-LEWIS: We do kind of need
like a psychedelic Dan
with like the word "awesome"--
there you go.
DAN GALPIN: So Frima actually
made one of favorite Android
games, which is a space
shooter for free.
And the game was cool, but the
best part about it was the
epically silly story that they
put together for it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That was cool.
By the way, I just want
to interrupt and--
do you realize that it took me
like 45 minutes to find those
damn Mandelbrot coordinates?
DAN GALPIN: [LAUGH], nice.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway,
go ahead.
DAN GALPIN: So we appreciate
the time and effort you put
into this show.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's a complete
waste of time, actually.
DAN GALPIN: It is.
But, you know, you
learn something.
So this game is a game
in which you
control a squad of nuns.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Already
I'm sold.
DAN GALPIN: So the only thing
about this game is that I find
that most of the time, I--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, that's cool.
I like that art style.
DAN GALPIN: The art
style is awesome.
Most of the time--
IAN NI-LEWIS: And this
is actually--
I have to admit, this is another
thing that we're
starting to notice is
that even that pause
button, that's cool.
Just a lot a little--
and this is one
thing that's nice about--
we were actually in a meeting
earlier, not today, but a
couple days ago.
And we were talking about what's
different between doing
apps and doing games.
And a big piece of it is
games are so awesome.
On Android, you always get a
completely different set of
ideas and design things.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, it's
like going to--
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's so cool.
DAN GALPIN: It's like a
designer's paradise.
Design whatever you want,
as long as it's awesome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And that
was sort of this--
yeah.
DAN GALPIN: And my hat is off,
by the way, to Frima's
designers on this one.
They did a beautiful job
with the art style.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
it's so pretty.
What do you call that?
It's like, I don't know,
"Powerpuff Girls" meets "The
Addams Family." It's like
this bizarre emo
cartoon, and it's great.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, these
are seriously emo
nuns that are in this.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's a nun?
DAN GALPIN: That's a nun.
Yeah, look at that.
See the hot nun with
the habit?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, man.
DAN GALPIN: I know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's like they
just invaded my nightmares.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, so this is
the burly-ass boss nun here
who takes things out
with her shotgun.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So she's
a tank nun?
DAN GALPIN: She's a tank nun.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice.
DAN GALPIN: You see there's
also different kinds of
characters.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well, what's
knife nun doing here?
DAN GALPIN: Knife nun is--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Kind of standing
back there, being eye candy?
What's going on there?
DAN GALPIN: She actually--
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think that's
actually a little bit
offensive to both nuns
and women as a whole.
DAN GALPIN: What?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Just, you
know, the hot nun.
DAN GALPIN: Why?
What's wrong with
nuns being hot?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually, what I'm
wondering is, how did she
get the eyepatch?
There she is in the act of
devoting her life to worship
and quiet contemplation.
How did she lose an eye?
DAN GALPIN: You know, that's one
of the great mysteries of
this game, actually.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I get the feeling
that the nuns in this
game aren't real nuns.
DAN GALPIN: It's
very possible.
They also like to hang around
in bikinis apparently.
So they're a new kind
of kick-butt nun.
Actually, nuns are pretty
kick-butt, by the way, in
general, just by
my experiences.
Those are some serious
badass--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Really?
Did you meet a lot of nuns
in Hebrew school?
DAN GALPIN: [LAUGH],
I actually did not
go to Hebrew school.
But no--
IAN NI-LEWIS: What kind
of a half-Jew are you?
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
But I will say that--
oh, here we are.
So the problem with this game
for me, by the way, is that
the game is actually well
thought out, but the controls
for the games are actually
mostly what I'm fighting.
And the game tries to make
things easy for me.
I say, I want to attack
that guy.
And it continuously attacks.
But I feel there's less visceral
pleasure in this.
And it's still annoying.
Because sometimes you're
dragging to say, I want to
attack this guy, and you miss,
and the nun just walks over.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Ooh, yeah,
that's rough.
DAN GALPIN: Or that guy just
doesn't get attacked because
he just happens to be
standing there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Hang on, though,
I think we need to--
two, three, four, [SINGING]
how do you solve a problem
like a skeleton?
DAN GALPIN: So I can also--
there's also special abilities
like I can make my nun
invisible there.
So I can click on her, and
I can say, I want to go
boom on this guy.
Take out this gate.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Gate?
Is that what we're calling it?
DAN GALPIN: It is the gate.
It is, I believe, some
sort of hell-gate or
something like that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Because that
resembles nothing
so much as a gate.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So anyway, so that's
the basic game.
The main issue with this game
that I had was that I kind of
my found myself fighting
the controls.
On the other hand--
IAN NI-LEWIS: By the way, I
think we should pause and
mention that our heads
are blocking a
massive amount of gameplay.
DAN GALPIN: That's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Also,
don't care.
It's our last show.
Deal with it.
Rock on.
DAN GALPIN: Rock on.
[LAUGHTER]
DAN GALPIN: So Ian, before the
show, said, Dan, take this
scene and sprinkle it liberally
throughout the show
wherever it's appropriate.
We're going to call this
the Dan awesome scene.
And so there--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, Phamster
has done an amazing job.
DAN GALPIN: As always.
So the main issues with "Nun
Attack" that I saw is I kind
of wanted to feel a little bit
more feedback when I actually
targeted someone.
Like I wanted it to make it
clear this nun was targeting
that character, and
I don't see that.
And so there's lots of times
where the nun does something I
don't expect.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So yeah, you drag,
and it wasn't obvious
when you could finish
your drag.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
And I really--
IAN NI-LEWIS: But why?
It seems like it would be so
obvious to just brighten that
character up or something.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, and that's
what I think needs to happen.
And also, once a character is
attacking someone, I want to
make it really obvious.
Like I want a little picture
of the guy or a little
direction, a little line
saying that this one is
attacking that one.
So there's a couple things I
think need to be done to make
the game better.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what I
think is a terrible idea?
DAN GALPIN: What?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Your picture
of a guy idea.
I like mine better.
DAN GALPIN: OK.
And then "Nun Attack" also needs
to get rid of verifying
the download every
time you launch,
because that just sucks.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
What is your dude doing?
I thought you were just--
are you actually doing a CRC
check on it or something?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
I wrote a little CRC checker.
And so it unzips the
entire file.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That was literally
just to pad your
resume, wasn't it?
It was like, 2012, wrote
a CRC check.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, that was
pretty much-- well, it was
actually because when I was
developing it, I was making a
download resume function.
And when I made the download
resume function, I wanted to
make sure that the
resumption--
the downloads were actually
getting done correctly.
So of course, the first thing
I did was wrote a verifier
that would verify the CRCs.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love it.
Dan wrote all of this over the
course of three months.
Now that doesn't sound like much
except when you consider
that we'd promised to have it
done in three weeks and not
having it done delayed
the entire feature.
DAN GALPIN: You know, you're
making me look bad here.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what
makes you look great, though?
DAN GALPIN: This hat.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And if you don't
go mullet on us, I don't know
what I'm gonna do.
DAN GALPIN: Cancel the show.
So let's--
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, I'm telling
you, it's either mullet or--
alternate possibility--
shaved.
DAN GALPIN: Shaved?
IAN NI-LEWIS: That
would be awesome,
especially with that beard.
DAN GALPIN: Oh yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm thinking
Kane from "Command and
Conquer."
DAN GALPIN: Yes, yes.
That would work.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Let's face it.
Everything Dan does is epic.
DAN GALPIN: So this game was
actually one of the ones that
was nominated, just in
case you thought I
was going to ignore--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, awesome.
Who nominated it?
DAN GALPIN: I don't know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Let's call
him nominator guy.
Nominator guy, let's
see how you did.
DAN GALPIN: The developer of the
game-- so this is a game
which looks like another game
that we actually saw.
Your goal is to get--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh man.
Is this a tilt game?
DAN GALPIN: It's a tilt game
where the goal is to get the--
in fact, it's just like a game
that used to, I think, have
sheep in it.
But now it has ghosts in it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You
are kidding me.
DAN GALPIN: It is
the same game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You
are kidding me.
DAN GALPIN: Nope.
IAN NI-LEWIS: OK, you know
what, nominator guy?
I began to suspect that
you have an ulterior
motive of some kind.
DAN GALPIN: Well, I actually
like the burning ghosts rather
than the sheep, honestly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I would
have gone with
burning goats, but OK.
DAN GALPIN: Goats.
Oh, and I've got to
avoid the fire.
No, the fire, we bounce
off of the fire.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I can't
see a thing here.
It's all fire and--
you know.
It's got a sort of spotlight
thing going on.
DAN GALPIN: So cool--
IAN NI-LEWIS: But
you know what?
OK, can I just say this?
DAN GALPIN: Box2D game,
yeah, yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Hang on.
You think it's Box2d?
You think it's that complex?
DAN GALPIN: It is Box2D because
it's using AndEngine.
So I'm pretty sure it's Box2D.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Eh, fair enough.
No, but what I was--
eh, go ahead.
I don't care.
DAN GALPIN: So first of all,
this guy actually, what I will
say, learned a lot from
professional game developers.
Because professional
game developers do
exactly this thing.
They take a game that's
based on sheep, and
they skin it for Halloween.
And then they're like, look
at my game, everyone.
I've got a Halloween game.
Not that we know any developer
who would ever do
something like that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right.
So when we say professional,
that's not necessarily a mark
of quality.
It just means they make money
from what they do.
DAN GALPIN: Well, honestly,
if you can skin a game
successfully, and actually, I
think this works better than
the original sheep game.
Because I never quite understood
why I was-- those
were sheep.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's a
really good point.
Now the storyline is better.
DAN GALPIN: It actually--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Hang
on, hang on.
I just got a message on
my Amp'd Mobile phone.
Let's see.
DAN GALPIN: Hello.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh,
it's Googleween.
DAN GALPIN: The Friday Games
Review has now become an ad
for acceptable.tv.
If you haven't seen
it, tune in.
All right.
So anyways, great job in
skinning your game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But
you know what?
What a horrible job of skinning
your interactions.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: How many dialogues
have we see now that
have not been cool?
DAN GALPIN: I know.
And it's sad.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I know it's
our system dialogue.
But I'm going to go out
on a limb here.
Yeah, let's just come
out of the closet.
Our system dialogues,
not cool.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
don't use them.
Actually, as a general rule,
we tell developers, even in
apps, not to use our system
dialogues for almost anything.
Because the reality is, you
almost never want to stop the
user's progress in the middle of
something unless it's sort
of like, this action
will destroy all of
your data, you know.
Would you really, really
want to do this?
Most of the time, if you're in
the middle of any kind of
progression, what you'd want to
see is a separate screen.
You'd want to see a true
interstitial screen rather
than a dialogue, even
within apps.
Or you'd want to see it be a
part of the existing screen.
In a game like this, what I want
to see is, take a look at
what happened with a game like
"Angry Birds," where you
actually see, yes, a dialogue.
But it's really an interstitial
screen.
It feels very, very much
part of the game.
And you get to see a whole
bunch of stats
about how you did.
And really, that would
be really nice.
I actually want to know how
many times did the ghost
bounce off the wall.
I want to know--
I don't know, anything about
the game that might be
interesting.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Actually,
that's true.
I always love stats.
Definitely, as I've been playing
a game, I don't know
if you've heard of it, little
bit of a new game for me,
"Radiant Defense"--
DAN GALPIN: You're playing
"Radiant Defense"?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
DAN GALPIN: Holy moly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And I think to
myself, wow, it'd be really
cool if I could get the
stats on this tower.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, know
how much it's killed
and stuff like that.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I like that.
That's a great idea.
So that was "DemonBall,"
by the way, which
was actually nominated.
I want to send props out to
"Greedy Spiders" for making
those changes.
I'm not to going to go through
the game because we're running
low on time.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We are?
DAN GALPIN: Relatively, yeah.
So there's a non-Halloween
game I just want to call
attention to because it comes
from Clapfoot, and I
absolutely really
love this game.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Wait,
wait, wait.
Who's Clapfoot again?
DAN GALPIN: Clapfoot
made "Tank Hero."
IAN NI-LEWIS: Oh, OK.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, those guys.
So this is their take--
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's cool.
That's good-looking.
DAN GALPIN: This is their
take on a shooting game.
And this is pretty cool
for a freemium
shooting game, actually.
They mostly nailed it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I totally like
that beginning scene.
But now, what are we--
we're basically looking at
a generic side-scroller?
DAN GALPIN: Yes, it's a
generic side-scroller.
IAN NI-LEWIS: But I like the
idea that they've got a
loadout screen and stuff.
Can you actually--
is there any kind of
RPG element to it?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
So basically, you slowly
build up your ship.
Or you can buy things to make
your ship more awesome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Nice.
DAN GALPIN: And as you go
through the levels, there
actually are four different
backgrounds in the game, and
you see them a lot, with lots
of different enemies that
slowly start coming.
Each level--
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's the tough
thing about side-scrollers.
You really need a lot of art.
DAN GALPIN: You need
a lot of art.
And so this game does not
have a lot of art.
But it's actually really
fun on top of that.
This is an hour--
IAN NI-LEWIS: I have to mention,
because this just
made me think of it,
so did you end
up playing the "Zaxxon"?
DAN GALPIN: I did not.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Didn't they end up
calling it "Zaxxon Escape"?
DAN GALPIN: It is, yeah.
And it looks awesome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, I gotta
give a shoutout to these
guys because they did some
interesting things.
Now of course, I'm sorry, name
of the studio because I'm
totally blanking on it.
It's the same guys that did--
DAN GALPIN: Free--
IAN NI-LEWIS: "SnowboardX,"
right?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, what was it?
IAN NI-LEWIS: FreeRange.
DAN GALPIN: FreeRange.
It was FreeRange.
OK.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So FreeRange and our buddy
Wayne, Wayne Karo, your last
name sounds like corn syrup.
But anyway--
DAN GALPIN: He's a sweet guy.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, no, awesome
guy, totally awesome.
I mean, the whole FreeRange
team, they've been in games
for a long, long time.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: [INAUDIBLE]
Tony Hawk, really cool stuff.
The snowboard game is great.
But anyway, so they put
out this thing.
And obviously, it's interesting
because there's a
lot of games that you could
say are inspired by other
games, when what you really mean
is total ripoff of this
other game.
"Zaxxon Escape" is inspired by
"Temple Run" in the most
classic way, in that it is--
DAN GALPIN: It's true
inspiration.
The game is heavily,
heavily different.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
And it adds a third dimension.
It's like "Temple Run"
meets "Descent."
So really cool stuff.
And they originally
showed it to us.
I think it was a
different name.
And then they hooked up and Sega
and they got the "Zaxxon"
name on it, which--
DAN GALPIN: Shh!
IAN NI-LEWIS: --was
absolutely cool.
DAN GALPIN: It was designed
as Zaxxon.
Shh.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It was,
absolutely.
Which I love.
I'm glad that they brought
that name back.
That is some cool stuff.
DAN GALPIN: So "Zaxxon," I can
tell you, many years ago, I
actually owned a "Zaxxon"
stand-up.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Wow.
DAN GALPIN: I know, I know.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You're like
that kid in that one
Richard Pryor movie.
You have everything.
DAN GALPIN: No.
But I did have a "Zaxxon"
stand-up, back when they came
down in price.
You can get them
for about $300.
IAN NI-LEWIS: He means $3,000.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know why?
DAN GALPIN: Thank you, thank
you, translator man.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Dan is
phenomenally wealthy.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, right.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Come on--
houses, exactly, and a Prius.
DAN GALPIN: Hey, all I can say
is that you drive a BMW.
IAN NI-LEWIS: How did you
get a Prius, anyway?
BMWs, in San Jose, Silicon
Valley, dude, you find those
like on the side of
the road, man.
DAN GALPIN: Well, certainly once
their lease has run out.
But yeah, no, this
is a lot of fun.
You can waste a lot of
time with this game.
And honestly, they did
a really, really
great job with it.
So good use of Android,
and I've been
really happy with it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Cool, cool.
DAN GALPIN: I wanted
to give a shoutout.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Now I have to ask,
though, is that really
full resolution?
DAN GALPIN: That is, as far as
I can tell, full resolution.
It's just that the artwork in
the back, the textures are a
little blurry.
IAN NI-LEWIS: It's
just the beer.
DAN GALPIN: No, the textures
are blurry.
You can see if you look at the
sharp lines around the
geometry, you can see that's
actually full resolution.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah,
I saw that.
So it's really just
the backgrounds.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So I guess
we're saying that's a
depth of field effect?
DAN GALPIN: No, it's just
low-resolution textures.
IAN NI-LEWIS: This screen,
though, is really cool.
I like this screen.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, yeah.
That screen is awesome.
It makes you think the game is
going to be perhaps a little
more epic than it actually is.
But I really love the game.
I thought they did a beautiful
job on it.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm sort of ready
to do my loadout into my
giant robot when I see
a screen like that.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, you're like,
[INAUDIBLE], exactly, exactly.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, that's
one thing we don't have enough
of is giant robot games.
They're very difficult to
do on a touchscreen.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah,
no, it's true.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, if
you're doing a giant robot
game, though, let me know.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know, I don't
know why you'd let me
know, but what the hell.
DAN GALPIN: So, and speaking
about letting us know, so I'm
not playing to take the
moderator down for this.
Because you never know when
we'll actually do another
games review.
We're not going to be doing them
weekly, that's for sure.
And if we do them, we're
going to try to--
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know what?
We're going to do them
guerrilla style.
One day, you'll be sitting in
your cafe in, I don't know.
You know, wherever you live,
be it Singapore, be it
Bangladesh, be it London,
the fashionable side,
any of these places.
Dan might just descend on you
and do a video game review.
DAN GALPIN: That is
a cue, Mr. Pham.
IAN NI-LEWIS: If you live
anywhere in the continental
United States, apart
from New York?
DAN GALPIN: Was there anything
on the livestream, by the way?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Probably not.
DAN GALPIN: Let's take a look.
Is there anything on
the livestream?
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yes.
So let's take questions
from the audience.
DAN GALPIN: Is there
an audience?
IAN NI-LEWIS: I love how Dan's
like, oh man, we gotta get
through these games.
No we don't.
DAN GALPIN: We got through
all of them.
IAN NI-LEWIS: What we've really
got to do is take
questions from the audience.
DAN GALPIN: All right.
So questions from
the audience.
DANIEL PHAM: People were
actually confused whether or
not this a Halloween-themed
show or not.
And it's probably because I
didn't bother to edit the
description or any
of the titles.
So sorry, guys.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Waiit.
Yeah, it totally is Halloween.
What's the matter?
You didn't edit what?
DANIEL PHAM: I didn't edit any
of the descriptions saying
that, oh, this is going to be
a Halloween-themed show.
We haven't done a themed
Friday Games
Review in a long time.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's true.
DAN GALPIN: We did announce it
on the last show, but that
doesn't mean anyone found out.
So sorry about that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: And also, I seem
to remember that Dan spent
most of last week under the
influence of some pretty
amazing London substances.
So--
DANIEL PHAM: That may
or may not be true.
I cannot confirm
nor deny that.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Right, right.
DAN GALPIN: We're did you guys
stay in London, by the way?
DANIEL PHAM: I stayed
in the Grosvenor.
DAN GALPIN: Oh, nice hotel.
Very nice hotel.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I guess.
Anyway.
DAN GALPIN: I miss the London
office and the truly amazing
coffee lab that they
have up there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
We stayed in, what, Belgravia,
Belgrave House?
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, Belgrave
House, which is awesome, too.
IAN NI-LEWIS: When I worked
for Xbox, we'd stay at St
Martin's Lane, which is the
most epic hotel ever.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We got some
deal there or something.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, I was gonna
say, our T and E is not as
epic as what you guys had
with the Xbox, so--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Well,
shit happens.
DAN GALPIN: So anything else
from the livestream that's
interesting?
DANIEL PHAM: Some people didn't
catch the first few
minutes of the show and catch
on to the fact that this is
going to be the last episode
for a while.
So for those of you tuning in
right now, this is going to be
the last show.
IAN NI-LEWIS: This is the final
show, final episode of
the Friday Games Review.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah.
Whatever happens with games,
we're still going to do--
we still care about games.
IAN NI-LEWIS: No, we've
had a great run.
I mean, over a year now, we've
been basically kicking back
about 2 o'clock in the
afternoon, helping ourselves
to some beer that Google bought,
and just ripping into
some games.
After which--
well, actually, what we used
to do was leave this studio
and go directly into another
meeting where we
just ripped on games.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, absolutely.
So--
IAN NI-LEWIS: Basically, people
grow, things become
more corporate, we add people
to the organization.
And all of the sudden, it's
like, dude, getting drunk on a
Friday, is that really cool?
And I'm like, yeah.
Well, OK, why don't you do
that on your own time?
I'm like, OK, fine.
DAN GALPIN: And actually, I
find that the more beer I
drink, the more I grow.
IAN NI-LEWIS: In some
dimensions, yes.
DAN GALPIN: Absolutely.
So yeah, we're going to be
doing more with games.
And I think that for
us, there's a
lot of exciting stuff.
We want to get together with our
buddies over at Chrome and
on the web side of things.
And as I said, I'm
really excited.
You heard me sort of alluding
to this last week.
But I'm really excited about
the new Chromebook.
I think it has the potential
to be a game monster.
And I want to see what
people do with it.
So I'm sort of going to be
looking at that side
of things as well.
But what I was going to
say is, keep throwing
stuff in the moderator.
You never know when we're going
to come back and do a
new games review.
It's just that we're not
doing it every week.
And if we do it again, we're
going to try to make it
interesting and make it part of
a technically themed show.
So it's going to be us sitting
here with a bunch of guys from
NVIDIA going through PerfHUD or
us sitting here with some
guys from our graphics team,
talking about how best to
utilize feature X and really try
to get into a little bit
more of the technical
discussion.
IAN NI-LEWIS: That's really what
it came down to, right?
Dan and I are engineers.
We've been writing computer
software for years and years.
And we put this together to
start by just showcasing some
games that we liked.
But it turned out that a lot
of the things that we were
saying about games were
just universally true
over and over again.
We kind of got bored with it.
And so we decided it would be
a lot more fun to do some
technical stuff.
And in the last couple weeks,
you've probably seen us geek
out about GPUs and things like
that because Dan knows one
thing about GPUs, that they're
either tiled or not, and he
has incredibly in-depth
knowledge about that one fact.
It's awesome.
He's so cute.
But other than that--
DAN GALPIN: No, no, it's true.
And actually, when I was
trying to look at the
"Zombiewood" shaders to see if
I could figure out anything
they were doing wrong, and
to be honest, I couldn't.
So I looked at it, and
I'm like, no, that
glClear even looks OK.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So anyway, the
point being that I think this
one's run its course.
But we're going to be coming
back with something bigger and
better later.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
And that does involve us
drinking more beer
between now and then.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I think there will
probably be beer involved
because when is there not beer
involved with games.
DAN GALPIN: That is true.
And you know, beer is
actually part of
Google culture on Fridays.
We do have--
IAN NI-LEWIS: That is true.
DAN GALPIN: TGIF [INAUDIBLE].
And that much is probably
not secret.
IAN NI-LEWIS: We just want to
give a shoutout to all the
people that have followed us for
a while now, Marcus, the
Austrian dude, and the other
guys that hate on us in all
the comments and stuff
like that.
DANIEL PHAM: Yeah, he actually
jumped into the comments and
said hi, so.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Hi dude.
DAN GALPIN: Hey, Marcus.
Awesome.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, and I'm
sorry that we never managed to
get that Austrian beer.
I couldn't find a place in
San Jose that sourced it.
DAN GALPIN: I blame America
for that one, actually.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Yeah, probably.
Anyway, so yeah, we
love you guys.
We're really happy that
you all tuned in.
We've always had a really good
audience for this show.
It's actually been one of the
best shows that we've done on
Android Developers Live.
But it's just time to move
on and actually--
OK, let me be perfectly
honest.
The thing is that--
DAN GALPIN: What?
IAN NI-LEWIS: When Dan Pham--
DAN GALPIN: When are
you not honest?
IAN NI-LEWIS: --sent in his
expense report for London,
Andy Rubin actually
looked at it.
DAN GALPIN: Dude!
IAN NI-LEWIS: And Billy's like,
hey, yeah, right, we're
sending Dan to London for this
great Android video thing.
And Andy's like, oh, maybe
I should watch that.
And Billy's like,
you know what?
We should shut down
the games review.
DAN GALPIN: I think
that pretty much
sums it up right there.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Anyway,
raise a glass guys.
Cheers.
We've had a super great time.
Dan, let us know, is there
anything else that we should
be asking or answering
on the feed before we
sign the hell off?
DANIEL PHAM: There's absolutely
nothing worth
mentioning.
IAN NI-LEWIS: You hear that,
YouTube commenters?
Quit acting like YouTube
commenters.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, exactly.
So anyways, this is goodbye.
But we'll certainly be around.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Watch
our Google+ feed.
Of course, we will continue to
be doing the App Clinic with
Reto Meier and myself on
Fridays, Android Design in
Action on Tuesdays, something
on Wednesdays that I have no
idea what it will be.
And Dan will be back at some
point doing something with
games, and it will be awesome.
DAN GALPIN: Exactly.
DANIEL PHAM: And probably
his hat, too.
One of his hats.
DAN GALPIN: Probably one
of my hats as well.
And you know, and perhaps I
might even come and make a
guest appearance on--
IAN NI-LEWIS: You know,
actually, that's probably what
we should have mentioned is the
whole thing has run its
course because you have
run out of hats.
DAN GALPIN: There is an endless
supply of new hats
that can be acquired.
But it's true, I did actually
have to go out and run out and
get this one last night.
IAN NI-LEWIS: All right.
Well, you can always reach us
through our Google+ stream,
which you can get to at
developer.android.com/+.
And we look forward to
hearing from you.
Give a shoutout to +Ian
Ni-Lewis, +Dan Galpin if you
want to talk to us directly.
Otherwise, just leave some
random comments, and somebody
will read them and respond.
I can almost guarantee it.
DAN GALPIN: Yeah, we actually
have real humans
that look at this.
IAN NI-LEWIS: So we've
reached the end.
I was going to buy some truly
epic beer today, but then I
ran out of time, money,
and inclination.
But Dead Guy Ale seems like
the right way to sign off.
DAN GALPIN: But you did make
the amazing Mandelbrot
background, so you're
completely forgiven.
IAN NI-LEWIS: There you go.
So all right.
And Dan Galpin-- you know, the
very first episode, you were
like, oh, no man.
I'm going to say my own name.
I was like, "I'm Ian Ni-Lewis.
With me, as always, is Dan
Galpin." You were like, oh,
no, I'm going to say "Dan
Galpin." The very last
fricking minute of the show,
you can't step up.
DAN GALPIN: As always,
I'm Dan Galpin.
IAN NI-LEWIS: I'm
Ian Ni-Lewis.
DAN GALPIN: And that's
the way it was.
Cheers.
IAN NI-LEWIS: Android games.
DAN GALPIN: Cheers.
[LAUGHING].